walker bueller has faced the cardinals
three times in his career
two great starts in 2018 15 shutout
innings in those two starts
and then in 2019 the last time he faced
him he gave up five runs over four
innings
now sees him for the first time since
here's dylan carlson one of those young
players having a good series for the
cardinals
chase is a high fast ball bueller with
his first strikeout of the game
quickly butane going high cheese
and it works it should work against this
team if they want to swing it one up
there by the letters
and paul goldschmidt is up goldsmith has
gone two for nine striking out five
times facing bueller
and hits a high fly ball into center
backing up bellinger
at the wall gone
deep center field and a one-nothing st
louis lead
paul goldschmidt with home run number
seven one to nothing cardinals
paul goldschmidt is just about to break
out always been a slow starter it's been
a typical thing in his career and then
he just gets red hot
and that was a pitch that was indeed up
in the zone but it wasn't as high
as the ones that we'd seen earlier in
this inning
carlos martinez was sensational in his
last start
he had a no-hitter going into the
seventh inning and then eventually took
a no decision in that game the cardinals
won it but he was really good
off the end of the bat to right long way
to go for williams still coming won't
get there
and bets has a lead off double the first
two have reached against martinez
first and second for turner ground ball
base hit for turner
bets gets the wave o'neill's got a
cannon his throw
off the glove the game's tied at one
runners advance and an rbi chance for
cody bellinger
ballinger rips a line drive to the right
field corner base hit that'll bring home
two he holds on with a single
and the dodgers lead 3-1 first and
second nobody out
gavin lux coming up swings at the first
pitch it's a highliner to center field
sending carlson back
off the wall bellinger will stop it
third and they've got all kinds of
issues on the bases
but a gift wrap run as bellinger comes
in
oh they were all hung up that throw
right there
got the dodgers out of two major
rundowns
cody bellinger oh no oh yes
smiles right looks like a kid playing
the game there
taylor's like i don't know where to go
bellinger then
starts to go back to home as the throw
gets away and taylor goes all right i
can go to third
so it's 4-1 second and third and still
nobody out now mckenn street ripped up
the middle and the beat goes on
they've got six before martinez has it
out
mckinstry's first hit since his return
and already mookie betts up for the
second time
turns your scorecards over
that's where the base looked alike two
hits in the inning
mckinstry headed for the plate he'll
score
7-1 dodgers carlos martinez done after
two-thirds of an inning seven runs
across
all three runners on base's
responsibility as well it's woodford
checking into the game with the bases
loaded
dodgers want to add on make this a
laugher early and it's bellinger at the
plate
bellinger hits one way up there
williams going back at the wall
goodbye grand slam
game busted wide open
11 run first inning and an early start
to the party tonight at dodger stadium
you got a ticket tonight and you were
driving here hoping to see some offense
compared to last night you are seeing it
early
cody bellinger had this high fly ball
take a ride on some wind right to the
top of the wall
and bounces out keys to the game score
11.
i think i changed that one it used to
say finish strong but i'm not sure we're
gonna have to finish strong just score
11 and keep going
get some swinging turns it up to 97 to
do it in the second cave
the o2 swung on and miss strike three
that's the fourth strikeout of the game
for bueller in the first down to the
third inning st louis led this game at
one point and a home run from this man
paul goldschmidt fielder sits him down
this time
gets him looking a little breaking ball
in the outside corner so two strikeouts
in the inning carlson's still the runner
at first base and nolan arenado
swinging a little looper down the right
field line this could drop
that's on the way and he dies and he
can't get it and that is fair
it's up against the screen arenado gets
into second base with a double
he drives in dylan carlson and it's 11
to two
dodgers one out pisner coming up
truly evaluated when you have smaller
samples especially kisner down on
strikes
sixth for buehler it's back to back
walks to load the bases
walker bueller who walked in the nine
pitch plate appearances last time
that's a fair ball it might not be a
grand slam
but it'll drive too bueller chugging for
second with a double
he'll dunk on him the fans love it and
you know walker loves it he was up there
trying to do something like he was back
in little league
and he made enough contact to have some
fun
first career double for bueller by the
way so a 13-2 lead
bets the other way third hood for murky
belts
into mckenzie bueller stopped at third
two touchdowns to a safety now dylan
carlson one for two
single to right and a run scored dylan
carlson
fly ball into the corner and right and
it's gone
just inside the foul pole a high
towering blast off the bat of dylan
carlson his sixth home run
stealing carlson picking it up with the
power here
second half of this road trip see how
quick and short he was right there
thomas four for 35 this year one two on
the way
ball strike three kneel down on strikes
eighth strike out of the game from
bueller one breaking ball gets you a
pop-up another breaking ball catches a
corner gets you a
looking k looking for one more out
and they'll edge will hit for himself
priority here is
knowledge to cover as much of this game
as a pitcher
as opposed to cutting into an 11-run
deficit with a pinch hitter
bounce past bueller behind the back
locks will step on it
and end the ending no runs two hits
three left
mueller's night is done dodgers lead 14
to three alex vasilya to try to get the
last three hours
bacia gets him to chase one gone vicia's
one-two pitch
got him back-to-back case open the ninth
for alex
see if he could finish the broadcast
[Applause]
toddrick's win 14-3 they out hit him
10-7 but they got it done
early joe 11 in the first we all win
tonight
most runs they've ever scored in a
regular season inning since moving to
l.a it matches what they did
in the nlcs last year against the braves
game three in the first game